and I want to tell you passion and from
the heart always always wins over
over-prepared and thinking from the head
Winston Churchill said the definition of
success is going from failure to failure
without losing your enthusiasm we think
we have a TD most of us don't have a TD
there's just too much coming at us and
we say yes to too many things
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from real estate
expert Dean Dr Yossi and my take on its
top ten mission success rule number
three is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always guys if you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below what quotes
around it so other people can be fired
and you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with yourself
joy think about how many times in your
life you had a massive win because you
had no confidence it doesn't exist right
if you were looking to go meet that girl
or that guy and you walked up you're
like hey you know I was hoping we could
come and get you now that doesn't work
you walk into business meeting
hey do you think we could no that
doesn't work go to talk to your kids
about something in school hey kids
no you need confidence you need the
energy need to be alive well if you know
me and been watching my videos that's me
I've made my career on enthusiasm and
energy and being in the right state of
mind having the confidence but you don't
the biggest myth is that you're born
with confidence no I was the shyest kid
in the world
I felt so insecure felt dumb I learned
how to manufacture the confidence and
after 25 years of being an entrepreneur
generating hundreds of millions of
dollars being blessed to touch the lives
of millions of people around the world
what I know for a fact is that you can
create the state of mind and the
confidence to live the best you to
unlock that inner hero
I literally flew to Arizona to meet a
media buyer and I said I have no idea
what I'm doing I just kept pushing and
and one of those things that I think
during the evolution of growing from
wherever you are to where you want to go
is do whatever you do best I mean do
whatever you're doing the best you can
knowing there's the bigger horizon so I
literally was working during the day on
cars I was a paint cars I've been doing
a collision repair at night I'd go work
on my apartments and I was a plumber and
Wow and hung Rock and I worked till
midnight on houses and I was tired but I
had a dream I knew I wanted to help
people do better so it made what I was
doing okay because I knew there was more
so the big problem I see is people want
more and they hate what they're doing so
that if they're in a they're in a state
of mind where god I just when I'm done
with this crap and someday I'll reach my
dreams and if you can flop that to go no
this is the gateway to my dreams I don't
care that I'm serving coffee or I'm
painting cars
I'm a teacher right now or I'm on my
sister's couch like this is what I have
to do and I have to do it the best
become a master just become a master
deficits and that's the income and the
security and the mindset that fuels the
next level it's not this is miserable I
hate it I feel the next level and now
I'm amazing it's like you need to master
that
yeah the process yeah you know I know
I've gone onstage in front of 10,000
people and I thought I should have more
PowerPoint I should have more reminders
and I just remember walking out and
saying I'm here to help rise these
people up to give them capabilities to
change their life it's my vision it's my
goal it's my obligation to use my unique
ability to just help these people and
live for my heart and all I could think
about is changing these people's lives
and when I got out there I wasn't
perfect on stage
I wasn't robotic and say the right
things I didn't have the crisp clear
PowerPoint but when I spoke from the
heart it overcame all of that and I get
to be one of the best presenters
wherever I go because I speak from the
heart now you might be saying Dean that
your unique ability and maybe that is
but I know for you in life there are
circumstances where you have to prepare
you have to do a PowerPoint you have to
do a presentation and I want to tell you
passion and from the heart always always
wins over over prepared and thinking
from the head what let me just ask you
some right now in the in the crazy
presidential race the GOP race you know
Ben Carson is probably the smartest guy
when it comes to book-smart out of the
whole group and I don't watch the news a
lot but I just read a lot and somebody
said this the other day and it just it
just hit me
someone said man ben Carson is probably
the smartest guy in that GOP race that's
going on whatever you think of it I'm
not going to share my opinion but you
know what the guy said when he was done
he's like but we all know the smartest
guy never wins and I was like wow we all
know that the smartest guy never wins
and what does that mean and it's kind of
what I'm sharing today I'm not saying
you shouldn't be smart I'm sure and so
many of you are probably way smarter
than I am but what I want to tell you is
enthusiasm and passion and living from
your heart to me
100% of the time outweighs being
over-prepared and robotic and trying to
think what to say I hope I'm getting the
right message across today I because
I've had this question from so many
people how are you so easy to talk on
camera on stage and I never have a good
answer I really fought through it that's
the answer I am here right now doing
this video for you because each week I
want to deliver you a nugget that you
could just place into your life and make
a tiny shift towards a better life so I
don't need a teleprompter I don't need a
script I didn't I come here and just
want to deliver and it's coming from my
heart now I have practice I've been on
video for 15 years I've been doing these
for seven eight years and maybe that's
not what you do but you're still going
to have these circumstances we have to
talk to your children talk to your
co-workers talk to your employees and
talk to your employer if you get stuck
in your head yes when you get stressed
that's when you get worried that's when
you try to remember what to say and you
leave to go oh why did I say that or why
didn't I say more but if you didn't go
in and say why am I going in and live
with passion and have it come from your
heart then that's truly you and you're
giving the answers you're supposed to
from the real you not the facade that
sometimes life makes us where we have
this ideal this image that everything
has to be great that we don't want any
problems because we're supposed to be
happy all the time or supposed to be
fulfilled there's those be full of joy
and nothing's supposed to go wrong but
the problems are what make us have the
other side of happiness the harder our
problems in the way we find solutions
the way we overcome those problems way
we process and be sad be hurt be annoyed
and push it out learn from and move on
the level of our problems is the level
of our success you know you might want
to be in a rock band and you want to
know the feel of being up on stage and
having all these people loving you and
cheering but if you don't want to go
through the the practices and the
rehearsals and carrying your stuff in
and out of out of you know dumpy little
bars and stuff like that all those years
then you don't want to take on that
problem of learning in order to have the
reward for being onstage and being a
musician right if you want to start your
own company and you just want to make
the money and drive the fancy cars like
some of these websites you see the
billion dollar website and a bunch of
people flashing money you know it makes
you think I want all
that happiness but I don't want the
problems to get there listen that old
saying the the smoothest Rock is in the
roughest part of the stream if you've
had problems if you are having a problem
in your life how you overcome that
problem how you figure out solutions is
the level of life that you get to live
what somebody told me once the level of
complexity you can handle is them just
correlates in so many ways to the amount
of money and their happiness you can
achieve and again I share this with my
kids all the time you don't know tall
until you know short you don't know
happy unless you know sad you don't know
cloudy days unless you know sunny days
and vice versa so what I'm sharing with
you is your problems are here to sharpen
us your problems are here to make us
stronger your problems are here to get
the find the solutions and the more
problems you can take on the more
problems you can get through and come
out strong on the other side the faster
your life will go to the next level
Winston Churchill said the definition of
success is going from failure to failure
without losing your enthusiasm take it
one step further from problems to
obstacles that you can overcome they
make you stronger they make you have
more grip and you have the ability to go
to the next level don't try to avoid
problems fix those problems get through
it find a solution and watch yourself
just step up the ladder of success
whether it's real estate whether it's
success in your own life your happiness
your joy your abundance you have the
opportunity to look at problems
differently as a blessing as a gift as
hard as some of them are get over them
and hit that next level the one you
deserve
I hit it big in real estate by time I
was 26 27 years old just by taking
action knocking on a million doors and
finally got something to do and no money
down deal with me I was 20 and then
another one I rolled that too next deal
and next deal and consumer action
consistent active and consistent you
know failing and getting back up right
the space between failures is really a
huge determining factor of your success
right it's like if you can fail fast you
can win quicker right how can you find
the time the energy the effort and the
nerve to start to make that first call
to put out that first bandit sign to put
up a Craigslist ad to start 225 to one
to call bank
how do you do that well this one today
is learning to say no now one thing I've
learned from the most successful people
on the planet if you want to say
millionaires I've been lucky enough to
meet billionaires the one thing I've
learned the more they say no the
wealthier they get now you may have
heard me say this before but it's that
important of a success principle it took
you a lot of yeses to get here yes over
time yes they're missing your kids you
know soccer or dance class yes to your
wife your husband getting upset because
you're working later yes to getting my
program yes to go into a live event yes
to getting the education yes yes yes yes
to your friends you know you if you're
watching this you are the busiest people
other people know they say if you want
something done ask somebody busy because
they know how to get things done that's
you you're the person in your family
amongst your friends I know it or else
you wouldn't be watching me they get
asked for emotional support financial
support for a ride for help for advice
so you are used to saying yes so this
week I want you to say no I want you to
make a list of the things that you must
say no to so you can focus on you
so you can make a massive impact for
your family you want to help family
members that need money say no to them
for a year becoming an incredible real
estate investor and then if you want to
cut them checks you can if you want to
give more to your church you want to
give more to charity say no for a little
while to so many things your brings
about all over the place we think we
have a DD most of us don't have a DD
there's just too much coming at us and
we say yes to too many things so here's
the assignment what can you figure out
to say no to this week because if you
say no to things that don't improve your
life don't improve your family's life
don't possibly increase your future
income or put you on a path to the goals
that you have to spend more time with
your family to get out of a job you hate
to pay off bills I don't know what they
are but you have to make a not a to-do
list but you have to make a list of what
not to do who are you going to say no to
who are you going to disappoint what are
you going to let go what habits are
eating up your time ties in the study of
Chi Zen is one step one little piece at
a time that's how do you eat an elephant
one bite at a time how do you win or run
a thousand mile race one step at a time
when JIP
and rebuilt after World War two they had
to adapt Kaizen because everything was
destroyed they looked at everything gone
they couldn't imagine trying to rebuild
Japan but what do they do they rebuilt
it one brick at a time one person at a
time one business at a time and it
turned into such a thriving country so
fast because they adapted Kaizen break
it up into small pieces you got a goal
take a bite today this moment when
you're done watching us right now go do
something towards your goal go send an
email call somebody say no say yes look
for a new job start to company just
create the URL if it's realistic go make
offers the only reason you think about
money is because if they're not enough
flowing into your life because when
money flows into your life you get to be
your best to you and the only reason I'm
sharing that is because so many people
have this deep-seated fear of making
extra money listen if you can cut a
check for a problem you don't have that
damn problem anymore
you worry about your kids you can cut a
check worried about credit card bills
worry about your business wonder about
your parents if you can kind of check
for that problem does it solve the
problem we still have to work on us it
doesn't fix us but it solves a lot of
problems so I ask you why you want to
make more money why you want to
diversify why you want to have a new
stream of income I just want to give you
this little example I hired a consultant
to help me be better with my students
get more people engaged to take action
he said to me sit down for two minutes
he goes well did you ever teach him the
seven levels deep of why they're doing
it I said no but if it helps them give
it to me he's like no you only have to
go you have to go through it or else I
won't give it to you I said fine I'll go
through it so the whole thing is I might
get wrap this up quick is whatever
answer you said when I said why do you
want to make more money ask the same
question again with that answer so on my
first question my first answer was I
want to have an incredible company that
changes the world while I make great
money and can help other people
that was my first dance sounds noble
right sounds like that's all from the
brain that's solid that's who we are we
got this company we're going to change
the world then he said to me Dean Ian
why is that important for you with my
answer why is it important for you to
have a solid business to help change
lives to make the money and I gave
another message from my from my head of
you know well I want to I want to set
the standard in my industry and get rid
of all the crap and
I did about four or five answers so I
want you to do this tonight go through
this seven times but what happens around
the fourth time you ask yourself that
question you flop from your head to your
heart so I got to the third one and I
said I never want to go backwards don't
even know where it came from you know as
a kid we were broke his crap I mean we
might wore hand-me-downs I got dropped
off far from school so the kids wouldn't
make fun of my mom's junky car I was
homeless at one point with my parents we
had no place to go I'd lie and tell my
friends I had no money at school I tell
them that you know I didn't feel like
eating because my mom didn't have the
bucks so I could eat that day no it's
not for me that shaped me I loved every
bit of it but I hated it and I realized
I didn't want to go backwards he said I
said that's it and he said to me and
Undine we're not done it's not it's
seven levels deep not five so why don't
you want to go backwards and it just hit
me and I remember I got emotional I got
goose bumps I said I never want my kids
to experience what I went through I
don't want to raise entitled kids but I
want them to have options I'm like
that's it I'm done they said no there's
one more I thought there could be and it
just hit me I said I want to be in
control of my life my parents got
married five times each if you're
military you moved a lot you know what
it's like every time you have friends
family new school you got to move I
moved 20 times by the time I was 19 and
I just realized at that very moment I
wanted to be in control my life I want
to dress the way I want I want to do the
work on one two where I want to raise my
kids the way I wanted no one was going
to tell me what to do in my adult life
and that was my why if you're having a
tough day your business is kicking your
ass and you just think you want
emotional or financial support of
financial freedom it's not enough to get
through a tough day but when you know
you're true why I went on stage four
years doing this week after week and I
get a woman come up I woman yesterday
said she want to make money to travel
the world I reminded me of a woman came
up her first why was I want to travel
the world after seven levels deep she
got to number one you know what she said
she was my physically abusive husband
left me two years ago on the way out the
door he said you're a pathetic loser
you'll never amount to anything and she
was I'm going to show him wrong screw
him that was her why is that a stronger
why then just want to travel the world
I had another guy stand up and he said I
want to change the youth in my
neighborhood there's not a lot of dads
no support I want to create this company
I've already started making money I'm
going to take it to a next level what a
strong why coming from his head you know
what his number one was that his mom
died before she knew that he said it she
set a good example and he felt he showed
her he was a loser while she was alive
and he was going to show her he was a
winner in her death is that a incredible
why I'm talking about these two I've
been blessed to meet presidents multiple
presidents I've met billionaires I've
been lucky to meet a lot of people and I
feel honored and blessed but all of them
have a kind of a humbleness of felt they
weren't ready and not as good as you
perceive him okay I'll give you an
example Derek said he went to England to
study and about four weeks before the
World Championship his coach came to him
and said get ready in two weeks you're
doing in a competition if you win that
and qualify you're going to the World
Championship and he said I'm not ready
for weeks I'm not ready I he thought he
was going to year after and she said
you're ready for it he said he pined
over and said no way I'm not ready and
she told them and the cool part is she
had he had a good mentor he had someone
that became like a second mom to him who
told him yes you're ready yes you're
ready he went to that event two weeks in
he won that he qualified for the World
Championship and then he's like I
qualified there but this is the world
everybody from the world is coming in I
can't do this I'm too young he started
going through all these excuses and then
like all entrepreneurs do it so I want
you to know we all think the same things
you do and all the things that are there
are there for everybody but one
difference is overcome your fear and
step it up and jump in the game because
listen you know Wayne Gretzky said you
miss a hundred percent of the shots you
don't take
he wanted to wait a whole nother year
when they when he went into the
competition
they had him ranked that he was finished
5th through 7th and he jumped in he did
the performances of his life and he won
the world championship feeling he wasn't
ready completely didn't want to do it I
mean think about his the how his life
probably changed
or ever forever and ever because he
actually overcame that fear didn't
listen to that demon those voices inside
tell me wasn't ready and he got in the
game and I want you to think about
future proofing your life what does that
mean you know technology is moving so
fast right now I was just an event last
week with Peter Diamandis the author of
abundance he's the creator of the XPrize
he was the one that put up the money for
the first ship that went into orbit that
wasn't part of NASA or part of a
government like the guy is just
unbelievably such a visionary and showed
where we're going you know right now
there's a hundred cars and Pittsburgh
ubers that are driving themselves
they're driverless cars Ford is making
driverless cars they're thinking that
uber alone in six or seven years will be
a hundred percent driverless that's
there's a million uber drivers
technology right now robots are going to
be cleaning our house not in a hundred
years like in ten robots are taking over
factories so what that means is a lot of
jobs are going to be lost a lot of
scarcity a lot of people getting scared
on certain times but really the
foundation of all success isn't the
magic widget the magic pill that gets
you rich the lucky invention all success
starts with our habits all successful
people don't they don't worry about the
change they embrace it they want it
Peter Diamandis is on stage and say
these see how this amazingness is but
what you have to think about is how do
you future-proof your life how do you
future-proof your income what are some
of the things that you can do to make
sure you're in a job that's sustainable
you're you create a business that's
sustainable
all of those are kind of to me abundant
they're everywhere but what happens is
when you back up five or six steps
that's where it all starts it all starts
with an abundant mindset it all starts
with having a vision and clarity of what
you really want out of your life it all
starts with not working on your
weaknesses and gaining your confidence
it all starts with knowing why you want
more and it starts with having the
habits that make you not overcome but
thrive during these uncertain times stop
worrying about technology stop worrying
about the
crazy politicians in today's world stop
letting the news affect you stop letting
the outside world control your knob turn
you up turn you down
you can future-proof your life by not
letting those thoughts that the future
is bad live inside your head if we focus
on what could go wrong if we focus on
robots and technology taking our job we
get small what I want you to start doing
is think how you can go big how you can
open up and say what is this amazing
technology a billion people going to be
coming online over the next ten years
all these changes this amazing
technology how can you step out in front
of it how can you be a part of something
people will always need how can you look
at it through glasses where it's
half-full where you can look it through
look at it through an abundance state
rather than a scarcity state life is
going to happen anyway technology is
going to happen anyway
we can focus on what's wrong with it or
how can I hurt us and that's how we feel
that's how we act and that's what we get
or we can find a way to find abundance
out of it find joy out of it find
excitement about the future and win that
you will find the path that will create
wealth will create joy if you're one of
my real estate students everybody will
always need real estate if you're not in
real estate whatever it is you do find
the angle if you're in the life coaching
business
everybody always need life coaching high
performance coaching that's two of a
million things you could be doing that
our future proof but the biggest thing I
want to share today what really future
proof future proofing your life means
it's having the right state of mind
being the observer of your thoughts and
find a way to focus on the future not
dragging that anchor of your past behind
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because dude buy houses
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next check out the link in description
and go and hack your vote I also want to
give a quick shout out to Tevin Fielder
Kevin thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and
tweeting it out and making animation
videos around it I really appreciate
this department and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the read so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is love
[Music]
is there a formula to like the most
successful infomercial like five or six
things that you must have yeah you know
it's so funny when I went dead before
when my brain there was a thought I had
my net never happens because I just got
off a plane it might be the Dramamine
but I went flat for a second because
what I was thinking when I was going to
tell you is you said how do you know it
was going to work
and what I'd share with anybody watching
in any kind of marketing or any kind of
persuasion or any kind of getting some
attracting somebody persuading someone
getting to take action when I look back
at those original infomercials I had two
things going for me I wasn't the
smartest guy in the world he struggled
reading insecure about that wasn't
college-educated I don't have a really
incredible vocabulary it's hard for me
to articulate certain words because I
just throw doubt in there yeah right but
what I had was is enthusiasm and
authenticity when I look back at those
infomercials and they hit like monsters
I mean one infomercial I did one of the
first sit-down in different and
informational I did to 150 million in
sales Wow one infomercial and Halawa
period was that over 18 months
Wow it's amazing and I look back at that
and I don't say that to brag and that
all that's not profit you know there of
course a lot of media here so I don't
want anybody I'm not and I barely say
anything about money I'm saying it to
make an impact because I wasn't the
smartest guy I didn't go to college I
didn't come from anything most people
watching are way further ahead than I
was when I start you weren't writing my
work but what I did have is I look back
even at those old shows from I'm
embarrassed to see myself and my New
York accent was like super heavy so I
grew up is I had authenticity and
enthusiasm and I think people could see
this guy really wants to help I wasn't
scripted it wasn't perfect I stuttered I
I said words wrong I mean I look at some
of those I used the wrong words in the
wrong content but it's still converted
and as I evolved so say what's the
foundation like as I evolved and I did
the first time I did a sit down Larry
King style infomercial he's the one that
gave me the idea for that then I did the
one where I was driving in my car the
reason I did that driving in my cars I
wanted people to know that I wasn't
using a teleprompter there wasn't
somebody scripting me there wasn't a
million cut it was me just driving was
it produced it was me driving from my
office I started it with a backpack
I said I'm going home you wanna take a
ride with me and I talked till I got
home you Briana and my son were probably
three and one I got to the door they
came running out thataway
Marshall that's cool right and that was
even planned they just ran out that was
home right but I did that because I
could tell the authenticity and the
enthusiasm I had to change people's live
was there I want other people in my
field to step it up and do better
because it will always keep me on my
toes
I want my competitors to step up their
game when I get frustrated on my
competitors it's because they're slack
and they're they're teaching
five-year-old strategies or they're not
they're hands-off they do an infomercial
let someone else run the education I
hate all that crap I would love for them
to be as good as up I would love for
somebody get close to me because all I
do is get more competitive and get
better and better competition is great I
can remember thinking throughout high
school and even in my early 20s maybe
not my early twenties I pretty quick
right around 20 years old I can go to
college right I didn't go to college I
barely got out of high school but I can
remember thinking in high school
whatever years that was is that you know
I hope someday I can get a job and make
a thousand bucks a week and just get by
and not that smart cuz I had trouble
reading I still can't read great but I
did I've just had dyslexia is what I
think it's been diagnosed now but I
still can't comprehend good when I read
but I didn't realize I was an audible
and visual learner I could listen to a
book and I'll memorize the whole book I
can watch somebody on stage and emulate
that if it fits my life but sometimes
we're judged by a scorecard that doesn't
it's an outdated scorecard
right so not only did we not have money
I also felt well I'm not smart enough to
go to school and something changed
around 17 18 years old just something
flipped and I just I noticed and this is
going to sound like it's a pitch for the
book and it's not but I noticed the
people in my town this little tiny town
I grew up in upstate New York the people
that had money the people that seemed
happier I don't know behind the scenes
but they seemed happier more fulfilled
they were more relaxed like life just
happened like they were walking up a
ladder instead of like my family seemed
like they're running on a treadmill you
know it's like we're going fast but
we're not going anywhere so why is this
guy and this woman is town doing so well
and I remember just obsessing on hmm and
and what I noticed it was I didn't I
didn't
call it habits I'd love to say I figured
this out twice but I realizes they just
did different things than my family and
my friends were doing and I just started
obsessing on that and I was young enough
and naive enough to just think I could
do it well you know I mean sometimes you
wish you could give that gift to
somebody in the 20s 30s or 70s right I
had the gift of being naive and a little
dumb and not listening to anybody I mean
I was in 1998 I did my first infomercial
well and most twenty years ago yeah
1998 oh my first one and my sister my
daughter's aunt my daughter's sitting
here it is my sister drove from Virginia
because by then so in 1990 I had I had
an apartment I had a collision shop I
had an auto sales and I was building
houses well doing it from from that
broke kid I was doing all over you when
you started that's probably in 1998 was
what 20 years ago is 28 29 years old